[Music]
welcome back everyone a bipartisan group
of centers unveiling a 908 billion
dollar stimulus plan it gives money to
small businesses
city states and extends unemployment
insurance but not everyone is on board
as our next guest fears
aoc and the squad could derail any
legislation coming from the senate
democratic west virginia senator joe
manchin is one of the lawmakers
behind that bipartisan bill that
includes senator cassidy and others
uh and mitt romney he joins us now
senator uh what made you say
uh the status quo is not okay and call
one eight hundred republican
and say let's try a deal well what
happened is nothing was happening
that's the problem right we've been
talking about and and our leadership's
been at a stalemate
uh both in the senate and over in the
house the people are hurting
in my state of west virginia they're
hurting in every state
and we're in a worse pandemic now as far
as the outbreak of the pandemic will get
much worse this first quarter we're
trying to get through the most difficult
times
that we've ever had and that's going to
be people that are losing everything as
far as all their benefits are running
out
at the end of december the economy
hasn't recovered there's more shut down
there's no outside dining
and a lot of inside dining has been shut
down so we have restaurants hurting we
have so much
that needs to be assisted here there was
560 billion roughly
560 billion left over from the first
cares package
and that's what leader mcconnell is
calling the skinny package he just wants
to get that out the door
we've put with democrats and republicans
working together another 348 billion to
that makes it 908
so it's only 908 of new money so people
who think it's too much
or people think it's not enough maybe
we've hit the sweet spot and we're
hoping
our leadership will look at this in a
very constructive way okay so
some of the things i'll just run through
them it's a lot of money 160 billion for
state and local governments so they can
decide
what they want to do with it no they
can't no they cannot
the language is much different we're not
laying we're not making the mistakes of
the past
and mitt romney and all my friends bill
cassidy myself susan collins mark warner
we are committed to making sure there's
accountability and responsibility
so are you worried for example democrats
or republicans always point out
uh a lot of these democratic-run cities
states not yours
uh have uh committed to a lot of these
funds
and pensions that are unsustainable
and they asked for the federal
government to bail them out and they
might use this pandemic as an excuse to
do that like new york and california
cannot can not cannot i can assure you
with my republican colleagues and the
way i feel also
and i've spoken to the governors on all
sides they know they cannot
cure their eels with this money that
won't happen 45 billion for
transportation
12 billion for community lender support
288 billion for small businesses we know
that hundreds of thousands of businesses
are not going to reopen
180 billion to extend unemployment
benefits even conservative florida wants
to do that
10 billion for broadband 10 billion for
child care 10 billion for the post
office 25 billion for nutrition
and agriculture and both in both sides
in this group
of how many have checked off on this
well we had 10 basically that worked on
it diligently for the last three weeks
what we have now brian it just keeps
growing
more people were seeing this is
something that can be doable this is
acceptable it can be passed
we just need our leadership to get on
board both sides of our leadership are
not happy with it
some want less some want more well the
bottom line is this is an emergency
relief package
it's not a do all end all brian that's
what we're trying to make him explain
and in leader mcconnell's skinny package
there's nothing for hospitals there's
nothing for nursing homes nothing
for nutrition or food there's nothing
for state and local there's nothing for
rental assistance
nothing for opiate treatment and nothing
for broadband
these are things that need to be done to
get through because the next quarter
is going to be tough if they want to do
more later if president-elect biden when
he's president
is able to do that we can come together
and see what else we need
this is what's needed now and both
democrats and republicans agree
and by camera on both sides of the aisle
in the house
and in the senate that's unbelievable
and senator i can't tell you how many
average everyday americans
have come up to me and said do you think
they're going to get something done in
the interim
yeah because you have to hit you're
talking about hundreds
over 100 000 small businesses that are
not coming back they say between four
and five million americans will be
permanently unemployed
what about the college kids graduating
nobody's hiring they're living in their
basement still wondering when their life
is going to get on track
well also if you look on our bill we
have four billion dollars for student
loan deferment just to give them a
little bit of relief through the first
quarter
this is strictly and what we call it's a
coveted emergency relief framework
we're putting the language to it now
hopefully we'll have all done by first
of the week and we're hoping
our leadership will work with us senator
right after the election one of the
first things that happened is
uh the democratic side kind of took aim
at each other and said
who came up with this to funding the
police it almost destroyed us and it
cost you state houses
cost you many seats uh in the house of
representatives
and maybe prevented you from getting the
senate and one of the people who fired
back at you is alexander ocasio-cortez
she said i find it amusing when
politicians try to diminish the
seriousness of our policy work
movement organizing and grassroots
fundraising to just some tweets because
you said all she does is tweet doesn't
really get her name on legislation
uh as serious politics is only done by
begging corporate ceos
for money through wax seal envelopes
delivered by
uh raven all right so she you're saying
she should get busy and stop tweeting
and she's saying to you
i am busy and it's much more than
tweeting what do you say
well my you know i don't have any
disrespect for congressman we just
differ we
disagree you can respectfully disagree
and we do that
my people in west virginia expect me to
represent them in a rational responsible
civil manner in a bipartisan independent
manner and i do that the best of my
ability
so i don't begrudge whatever she does
i'm just saying that
congresswoman has the right to do what
she's doing she represents her people
they've elected her
it's not who we are we're not going to
defund the police there's not one
senator
democrat senator that supports defunding
the police
if anything we think there should be
more investments made
to better equip better train continuing
education
so they have the social changes and know
them better as they have to deal with
them
there's so much more that has to be done
defunding is not an option on the table
it might be in certain people's district
but no senator
no democrat or republican i've ever
heard would defund the police in the
senate
she says she's winning well she has a
lot of following and i understand that
and you know everyone has the right to
do what they want to do on that
but you can see the support if the
support is not in the legislature in the
senate or in the house
don't you think you ought to find
something that you can get support that
we can work towards the middle to pass
people don't run their lives from the
extremes uh brian they don't do it
they're in their businesses from the
extremes
we all come together and make rational
decisions that's all i'm asking them to
do
let's be americans come together now
we've had a very divisive election
and we're still split as a nation we've
got to start healing
and coming together right and you might
have no choice because you're going to
get nothing done without doing that
and senator joe manchin will be the
fulcrum for that if that can happen
senator joe manchin
can't thank you enough thank you brian
hey happy holidays to you all all right
hope you guys can
just get something done we'll get it
done we're going to stay here until we
do get it done brian
we're not going home for christmas
either and tell the people we didn't do
anything
i hear you meanwhile thank you senator
joe manchin west virginia